outside it is not going to be boring
today because we got to be fighting
these challenging winds we've got a few
clouds around out there and you can see
the camera shaking around
unfortunately that wind is just going to
carry all that pollen too all of ragweed
grasses still all high counts and
unfortunately it is going to be
unhealthy levels of dust in the air
especially for sensitive groups those
people with with breathing challenges
already if you have bronchitis asthma
emphysema really it'd be best probably
to limit your time outdoors today we're
looking at 40 plus mile an hour winds
for most areas some have already seen 60
plus kyle canyon the spring mountains
have already been under a high wind
warning this morning that changed
overnight a blue diamond 50 plus mile an
hour winds mountain springs summit 40
plus and many neighborhoods around the
valley have already seen 30 plus mile an
hour winds we're pretty warm we're in
the 70s mainly because we topped out in
the low 90s yesterday and now we've got
the winds on top of that 73 up at indian
springs 69 in boulder city 68 in prom 75
in laughlin mesquite in the upper 60s
and we've got 45 in caliente 50 in
tonopah in reno this morning reno will
get in on maybe a little taste of this
rain and snow along the cold front cold
front still way up north they've got
wind advisories up in western nevada as
we do in southern nevada but here's that
high wind warning national weather
service elevated that overnight because
we had those 60 to 70 mile an hour winds
in the spring mountains for the las
vegas valley and other areas we'll be
looking at 9 a.m start for the wind
advisory until 9 p.m same for fire
weather warnings dry gusty winds just
elevating the fire weather concerns
today down south in arizona they've got
a wildfire now that's south of prescott
this is the crooks fire they're
evacuating people nearby
this has been growing quickly it was
discovered early yesterday it's over 500
acres zero percent containment you know
we're getting into fire season which is
almost year round now just because
we still have drought conditions that
we're fighting and these dry windy days
it just makes things worse so please be
careful with anything that can get a
fire started today 87 degrees will stay
extra warm and we'll look for those 40
45 mile an hour winds that should relax
a little bit over the valley but still
breezy to windy at times and then breezy
wednesday temperatures slide a little
bit and then windy again thursday ahead
of a colder system cooler
with low 70s for highs friday afternoon
and we could see a chance of some
showers or afternoon thunderstorms on
friday and then it looks like we'll have
a fairly quiet and more pleasant weekend
up to 80 on sunday